one of the more unheralded offenders in  the NBA and Martin gets to the rim  finishes just he knows what he's doing  a big part of it 19 for years says  knocks down his first three-pointer was  hopeful for and you see Poole come from  the baseline side and harden before the  double-team gets there without shooting  the ball well so far this step back  again  [Applause]  [Music]  starting to get into rhythm and here's  hard that's a thing of beauty  great finish step back three lightening  it up here on the second plus he got hit  on the elbow and a chance for a  four-point play great versatility at  that end of the floor  Westbrook three-pointer that's good and  that's the play making you're talking  about Spelman great recovery especially  after the offensive rebound hardening  for trade well it missed his first floor  from downtown he's at his next war and  just like that he's come 22 points at  halftime final seconds hard drive gets  his side YF his girl